[Music]
[Applause]
he is t roy aikman he's the fox nfl
analyst pro football hall of famer won
three super bowls and anytime a guest
brings us beer we love it troy joins us
on behalf of eight for the drinker who
consistently puts in the hard work as we
do troy and his team are conscious of
what we put into our bodies and the
options for light refreshing beer that's
brewed with organic ingredients
virtually non-existent until now as we
make way for
troy aikman
number eight looking good
hi buddy good to see you good to see you
yes sir that's all right hey guys what's
going on
look like you could still play and you
you look like you've uh added some some
muscle there
let's do this
troy aikman benching contest yeah one
rep one rep paulie i'll start with you
oh boy uh wait he's looking pretty good
uh i'm gonna go
265 for one sixty-five seaton i'm going
355. wow
aggressive yeah
i'm gonna say 317.
i'm gonna go uh i'm gonna get one rep
am i gonna answer am i gonna answer that
question yeah yeah i have no idea i mean
i don't i don't
wait you don't bench
i don't do well not
i do dumbbells
okay and i don't do like one time i'm
not larry allen you know i don't know
you know
in your debt i'm not that young anymore
in your day what could you bench uh 325
oh whoa okay all right what could larry
allen bench i think he's uh he's on
youtube i i i'm going to get it wrong
was it 700 pounds or something or
like a volvo
is he is he the strongest man you've
ever been around yeah yeah like not even
close not even closer man a few words
and uh i mean obviously a great player
but by far the strongest
feels like he's underrated
really it like you forget because you
know he never was somebody was out doing
interviews he never talked himself up i
know defensive lineman knew about yeah i
mean for a guy who could be all pro at
guard and then we lost our tackle and he
moves out to tackle he was all pro a
tackle and i mean he could do anything
he was
yeah i i know that maybe amongst the
public for sure because he was so quiet
uh
but i think amongst those that played
with him and certainly those that played
against him uh
yeah nobody they called it the larry
allen flu that guys would just not be
able to play that day
um we were we brought this up last hour
better athlete d honor bo jackson
oh gosh
i mean i'd have to say dion because he's
my teammate but no disrespect to bo
jackson i i think both of them what i
mean i think if you talk about
underrated i think what those two were
able to do
and do it at the level that they did it
is pretty remarkable i mean there's a
lot of guys we i mean i'm sure you
played all sports i played baseball and
football and basketball and baseball was
my first love and i felt that
you know i maybe could have gone on and
played collegiately and i think there's
something inside all of us that thinks
yeah maybe you could have made it in the
big leagues but i mean those guys they
they play for real and to be able to do
both uh it's a it's a it's an athlete
that we just don't know about were you a
pitcher pitcher and shortstop and uh
i was getting looked at to get drafted
by the mets they wanted me as a catcher
or an outfielder which i'd never done
i'm not sure why but
they wanted me but they didn't want me
doing what i'd been doing so i don't
know how that worked and then tom brady
got drafted by the expos as a kid
yeah well i never knew that yeah i think
uh i think i knew everything else about
tom brady i've had enough of his games
but i didn't know that do you get tired
though when somebody comes up and says
oh hey so uh do you know tom brady or
what do you think of tom brady um
not so much with that but you know those
they they usually want to tell me that
they know emmitt smith and
michael irvin and uh
well so do i you know
do you ever get confused
about on the street
like if somebody comes up to you they
say hey i was going to say um
who i get confused for a lot is john
elway
and when i'm in colorado then it is only
more but but if i ever get confused for
somebody it's usually john and i finally
asked john hey do you ever get confused
about me he goes all the time
and the other one is uh harry connick jr
which i
you know i think when they i think when
people see me they know quarterback and
you know i understand maybe why there's
some confusion with me and john
although i don't think john and i look
alike either but the harry connick i
really don't quite understand that's a
good comparison though which one harry
connick oh okay yeah well i'll take it i
mean i feel bad for him
it's an upgrade for me i i do know that
so yeah and harry connick now people are
starting to say i look like jay-z so i
don't even you know i mean
there's there's some meme going around
i'm like okay
what was it like to be single and be the
quarterback of the cowboys
uh
you know it was good it was good
is it dangerous
uh i wouldn't say dangerous uh i think
my
my biggest problem was uh you couldn't
you weren't it wasn't a it wasn't a
cowboys rule it was a cheerleader's rule
he couldn't date the cheerleaders
and
but i still did some
and and it didn't fare well for those
cheerleaders when when
when people found out but uh wait that
save their jobs
could i save their jobs no i
i couldn't they they're they're a
totally separate entity
um
but yeah it was good
[Laughter]
you'd rather talk about beer than you
would
yeah you're dating like yeah when did
you get to the point where you go i'm
gonna make my own beer uh two years ago
and you know i worked at a at a beer
distributorship when i was in college
and i've had a lot of friends that are
in the in the business
but i never thought i'd make beer
but i met my now partners through a
mutual friend and we started talking
about it
and felt that if hey we could do a light
beer a local low-carb beer
something that complemented my lifestyle
that that'd be great because we felt
that what was in the marketplace had
been there a long time needed needed
something new something fresh
and so ate then was born and what's
unique about this beer dan is that it
has no adjuncts and no fillers meaning
no corn no rice no syrups no added
sugars it's 100 organic grains so i
always refer to it as a better for you
beer
i worked out my health and wellness is
really important to me but i also enjoy
times with family and friends and and i
like beer so
uh to be able to make a beer that i felt
complimented the hard work that you put
in during the week uh we made this and
it's been really well received it's
exclusive to texas
and uh really fired up about it we just
launched february first and we'll be in
stores in the spring
so this is bootlegging right now outside
of texas
it is bootlegging yeah those cans let me
tell you something those cans are hard
to get
they're i mean they're they're a hot
commodity do you like the packaging yes
yeah it's clean well you don't act as as
excited about it as i haven't had it i
like a beer okay i'm not here to look at
the package okay i'm gonna drink it but
look at that i mean that's that's it's 7
30 in the morning troy come on well i
was asked i was asked what what what it
pairs with uh what kind of foods it
pairs with and i said heck it pairs with
bacon and eggs if you wanted
did you ever play a game where you were
hungover no heavens no well you have a
lot of quarterbacks who have in his yeah
no no no no i i never drank uh never
drank four game and and and have never
been a real big drinker to begin with
but now after games uh i'd wake up the
day after games with some hangovers
especially after some super bowls yeah
best super bowl that you uh celebrated
after uh
probably the
second one in atlanta the first one
uh
we were all new at it we had a team
party and you get there and the parties
are all sponsors and so
i was late getting to the party i was
held up at the stadium for interviews
and things of that nature and and then
you get to the party and you couldn't
even find your teammates so i i left and
it and then wound up hanging out with a
bunch of media guys at the bar and and
then the next year fortunately there was
a next year went back and and had a
little better plan and so
arranged to have a private room with
teammates and and then a few people that
were in town it was and it was awesome i
mean it's the
you can only imagine it's the greatest
night of your life to win a super bowl
and then the celebration that takes
place after and
i'm jealous because uh
stafford or borough won they're going to
get to do it this week but you never
went to michael irvin's after super bowl
parties did you uh i did not
i did not did you get invited
um i'm sure i did i
i think irvin you know he he takes all
comers
i think you just show up you're invited
how would you guys have done with social
media uh we we would have been we would
have been all right i mean
it it definitely impacts the the
activities but
i think that players would be smart i
think the the players of my air and not
just my team but i think the players in
my era would have been smart about it
and i think the players are now for the
most part it's definitely had an impact
it's had an impact on our business i'm
sure it's had an impact on your business
but even broadcasting games social media
has had an impact on what we do how do
you take criticism as a broadcaster as
opposed to how you took it as a court uh
well i think i take it well i've always
been good at constructive criticism and
uh i i will say i do read the tweets i
mean i not all of them i mean but i read
them i i find them pretty funny there's
some funny guys out there some i mean
some pretty you know you really start
laughing you know
if you don't take it too seriously but
yeah i think the
even though there wasn't social media
when i was playing i do think that the
criticism you take as a franchise
quarterback uh especially in dallas i
mean it can be pretty intense when
you're not playing particularly well i
think it prepares you for
whatever you get into after that when
there's public scrutiny and i think it
helped me in this job that you just
understand it's just part of the job and
you don't really let it affect you too
much we've talked a lot about the
bengals offensive line going against the
rams defensive line as a quarterback how
do you make your offensive line better
than what it really is get the ball out
of your hands i mean really uh that's
essentially what it is the rams know
that too right so everyone the ramps
play that that's the formula uh and then
they try to run the ball because if you
just get into a game where you're
throwing the ball then it's it's almost
impossible there's just not
there's not many offensive lines if any
that can hold up against this group so
you've got it it becomes a team effort
in order to beat the rams you've got to
have a defense that holds the score down
so that you can continue to run the ball
and even if you're not running the ball
uh that effectively you've got to be
able to stay with it and then get the
ball out of your hands quick and then
max protect when you can to take your
shots down the field i think if you look
at when san francisco
week 10 beat the rams they ran the ball
44 times they didn't run it particularly
well they only had three and a half
yards per carry but they got 44
uh carries in that game but the big
thing is they converted on third down
and that that ultimately if you're gonna
play that style of game and try to
shorten the game play great defense keep
the score down you've got to offensively
convert on third downs and and if you
don't then then you're in danger of
of the game getting away from you how
would you describe joe burrow if i had
never seen him play
oh
um
i
i love the way he plays i love the way
he played in college
what i like about him most however and
why i think he is a great player
because they all have ability i mean i
always hear the phrase this guy can make
all the throws and and i i don't even
know what that means i mean i know what
it means it means he can make all the
throws but who the hell can't make all
the throws i mean if you can't make a
throw you probably shouldn't be a
starter in the nfl there's only 32 of
these jobs and so
uh he's he's really talented but i think
when you start looking at quarterbacks
because it's always a flip of the coin
as far as who's going to be successful
as a first round pick and who's not
who's going to make it who's going to be
regarded ultimately as someone who
didn't live up to his billing i i think
there's more to it i think it's the
intangibles and he clearly has it so
he's got an edge to him that right from
the beginning even last year you know
right from the start and even when he
was coming out of college you could just
tell this guy's wired a little bit
differently nothing's too big for him he
he's confident he's going to be able to
come in and compete and then the
organization did a good job around him
but
i'm i'm a big fan i mean a big fan of
his uh love everything about him love
the way he carries himself i wish i had
as much swag as he did in the locker
room uh the the cigars are awesome the
the whatever he's doing and you know i
mean
the whole package is phenomenal but were
you cocky at any was in your career no
no that's just uh
no
i was confident i mean i was confident
but i i would never have been uh
described as cocky or brash in in in the
and i think that he he walks that fine
line to where i don't think he's
offensive i think he handles questions
extremely well even controversial
moments uh when he's been kind of drug
into some things because of what people
have said he handles it all very well um
and so
i'm i'm excited to follow his career i
hated when he got injured you know with
the knee and how is he going to respond
to that but
and i and i'll go a step further
a couple years ago a few years ago it
was the jacksonville jaguars they make
it to the fc championship game a
franchise that hadn't had much success
and then last year was cleveland browns
you know and you think of the dog pound
and all the great browns fans over the
years and hadn't had much to root for
now the bengals i just i love seeing it
i i love it it's great for the nfl it's
great for those cities that have those
fans that haven't had a chance to really
get excited for post-season play and
what he's done and and zach taylor and
all of them uh is is is great hats off
to that organization but you know it's
almost like they get a hall pass i know
the bengals want to win
maybe they don't you know people don't
expect them to win but they do but then
you juxtapose that to matthew stafford
like the pressure on the rams playing a
home super bowl yeah and if he wins he's
probably going into the hall of fame if
he wins this super bowl yeah
that pressure like when you won your
first one
what was the pressure like when you went
back for the second time when you were
expected to win well there there's still
that pressure i mean i wouldn't say
because we had won a super bowl that
that then there's not as much pressure
um there'd be more i would yeah
in some ways yeah i think in some ways i
think it's how i i heard matthew
stafford uh and it's something that they
talk about internally and i know sean
mcvay does that and and i like this
phrase that pressure is a privilege uh i
like that because you have to play in
big games in order for the there to be
pressure they're i'm not going to name
teams i've done that before and then and
then then the twitter world wakes up and
then they you know but there are teams
in this league that don't feel much
pressure and and when they get out of
september there's no pressure on them
they just go play
and for matthew stafford and the rams
when stafford was traded for
to know i mean the questions were always
and we had their games is
how's he going to play in the big game
how is he going to handle this because
in detroit he didn't win a playoff game
he didn't have a good record against
teams with 500 records and and all of
that and and what he has proven
is what i knew and really what my career
was about if if you have good players on
your team and you have good coaching as
a quarterback you have a chance to have
to play well and have a really good year
and he's been able to do that he's
played great he's been a big part of it
and i'm just really proud of matthew
i've known him he grew up in my backyard
where i live now in dallas and i've been
real proud of how he's handled the
pressure of this year and the
expectations he wanted to go to la he
wanted to do what he's doing now in la
and detroit i talked to him before the
draft i said do you really want to be
drafted by the lions the lions obviously
weren't very good at the time and he
wanted to turn that program around and
it unfortunately just didn't happen for
him but i know lions fans respect them
and appreciate them and uh they're out
in in droves to support him and for the
rams and matthew stafford to be in the
super bowl which is what the
only expectation was of course the plan
is to win it is pretty remarkable it
usually doesn't happen that way
do you hold a grudge against any player
not now no nothing that happened in your
career cheating i don't i don't hold a
grudge against anyone in my life right
now um and and it's a good feeling you
know um not to get weird but i you know
i've been meditating for about eight
years uh got into mindfulness and and
it's part of the the whole wellness
program which circles back even uh in a
roundabout way to the beer but uh yeah i
don't i don't have a grudge i have no
resentment towards anyone and uh
and it feels good did you have a grudge
against somebody i mean back in the day
you at one time but uh no i'm kidding
yeah
there are other guys
like i can name a couple that no i you
know i'm kidding with you i can tell by
your face like oh no um sometimes my
timing's not as good as it needs to be
you know my delivery but but no i've
always loved being on your show because
i was just commenting before i came on
that the reason i've enjoyed it so much
is the questions that you ask are
questions i don't get asked you know
they're always outside the box and and
and i like that so
i you know i've always thought the world
to you but but yeah i've had grudges in
the past and uh
and then i've just learned that
ultimately you're the one who suffers
from that and uh so i've i've been able
to reconcile those and
and now some of those that that i feel
like
that we did have grudges against one
another uh are some of uh are some of my
closest friends which is amazing final
question are you sending us beer
100
okay all right 100
fair enough because i might crack one
but after 8 o'clock this morning
yeah we wait i mean
that's the discipline you want and
that's what i've got it's eight o'clock
somewhere
uh he's t roy aikman as michael irvin
calls why did he call you t roy
well they used to call me roy okay a lot
of people do call me t roy and i think
you know it's kind of like a rod or you
know however there's a t and then
there's a roy you know so it's t-roy no
i got it i understood it
i don't you help this guy i'm a little
slow oh that's right it's tea and it's
roy there you go
the beer is called eight for the drinker
who consistently puts in the hard work
uh troy and his team uh are very
conscious of what they put in their
bodies and it's a light refreshing beer
that's brewed with organic ingredients
and uh those kind of beers are virtually
non-existent congrats on this good luck
with this oh it's great to see you
that's uh t roy aikman we'll uh come
back more phone calls after this
so dan we were going to audition if troy
ever needed like a spokesperson
oh i know we're eight yeah we're we
can't push products good i was thinking
you know my thing
now i look like an athlete
okay
it's for people with fit lifestyle and
clearly but guys like we can still drink
it right i mean look at y'all clearly
for those of us who are conscious about
what we put in our bodies you forfeit
fill the bill i mean we do y'all are
good but is this sort of the an eight in
there with yes look at this okay i see
what's the logo is a colon but on a
white can very nice hold up it's like an
eight
yeah
see
we're kind of under appreciate he was
questioning my intelligence
how would you uh
i would say
first rate don't wait don't be late
eight
i saw it what he had a full beer
yesterday i did i drank like something
yeah because
he won't drink unless there's a pretty
woman there she's like just try it
he did all right
you need to take that
uh it's possible
thank you thank you the best thank you
thanks for taking care thank you buddy
thank you so much
thank you